Republicans on the House Intelligence
Committee are launching a new offensive
tonight regarding alleged surveillance
abuse during the 2016 election that goes
beyond the FBI and the Justice
Department chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Herridge has the
latest tonight with this letter to
current and former intelligence law
enforcement and State Department
officials the Republican chairman of the
House Intelligence Committee launched
phase two of the committee's Trump
dossier investigation
chairman Devin Nunez posed a string of
dossier related questions covering when
officials learned the DNC and Clinton
campaign paid for the research by former
British spy Christopher Steele as well
as how the dossier was used to secure
one or more surveillance warrants Fox
News has learned the questionnaire
including a threat to subpoena
information went to former FBI director
James Comey former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper and former
CIA director John Brennan among others
the Republican staff memo released
earlier this month said the FBI and
Justice Department knew about the
dossiers Democratic roots when it asked
the National Security Court 18 days
before the 2016 election to collect
Trump campaign aide Carter pages
communications almost a year later
Brennan testified he still didn't know
the whole dossier story director Brennan
do you know who commissioned the Steele
dossier I don't you know if the bureau
ever relied on the steel dossier as any
as part of any court filings
applications petitions pleadings I have
no awareness in a separate development
London lawyer Alex vanderzwaan entered a
Washington DC federal court and pled
guilty to lying to special counsel
investigators vanderzwaan whose
father-in-law is a Russian oligarch
suing over the Trump dossier lied about
his communications two months before the
presidential election with Rick gates
along with his business partner and
former Trump campaign Chairman Paul
Manafort Gates was indicted on money
laundering charges by the special
counsel a White House spokesman said the
lawyers guilty plea is many steps
removed from the special counsels of
collusion mandate this has to do with an
attorney representing one of the
individuals who has already been
indicted has nothing to do with actions
related to this president according
servers speculate the guilty plea places
more pressure on gates to cut a deal and
cooperate with the special counsel
against Manta fort understand
Guidelines vanderzwaan faces up to five
years in prison and a $250,000 fine but
due to his cooperation it could be six
months in prison and to find not to
exceed $10,000 his sentencing is
scheduled for early April okay captain
thank you